it is exclusive summer dining provided
by local chefs in one of the most
beautiful settings in southern nevada
we're talking about pine dining and some
of the upcoming culinary experiences
with the general manager of ellis island
christina ellis and chef ismaila romano
welcome you two thanks for being here
thanks for having us christina i love
this pine dining experience you've
talked about it on the show before
people missed it tell us what it's all
about so pine dining is a food and
beverage experience we're hosting at the
site of mount charleston lodge so
las vegas is favorite chefs go up there
saturdays we have a cookout style event
and sunday's a chef's table event and
you switch the
different nights with different chefs
different fare it's it's all changing
and it helps to benefit local
organizations yes so every week we
donate all the proceeds to the charity
of the chef's choice oh that is so
amazing and
is my ellie you're up this weekend
how exciting so what what's going to be
on your menu and uh
are you going to show us how to make it
yes so we're going to do um
zlo roasted pocket as a
as a sandwich also oh you sound so good
saying that can you say that one more
time
oh i love that okay
what is it
this also is a vegetarian option which
is uh souther
eggplant okay and slow cook in a tomato
sauce and finish with the ricotta salata
and fresh
basil and mint oh let's make this let's
see so he made this potassium the
focaccia is make fresh every day
and you can even see look at that
oh my gosh
i already smell it smells so fresh and
so with these events christina people
can
taste the variety of some of the the
great chefs here in southern nevada yes
so this weekend we have a collaboration
it's all italian bites and pizza so we
have you know
all the all the best metro pizza via
focaccia with ishmaeli there we have
papa pizza monzu
i mean all an amazing menu of food and
so you'll get to try bites from each
different chef um and then this coming
weekend we have gina and her team from
la strega for our chef's table oh that's
amazing now chef that's the eggplant on
there the egg plants okay
and this is finished with some ricotta
salata this just looks incredible now
the you get to choose the organizations
you want to help who have you
decided to choose this this week
this week it's the candlelighters the
candlelighters oh they do so many great
things for the children and and with the
cancer childhood uh cancer that is so
amazing and yeah you can have a good
time while you're helping out is that
the basil there yes there's a bezel and
mint both together oh what a great and
that looks like something that you know
a vegetarian can enjoy and even if you
eat meat that looks pretty hearty
incredible if you want to go again how
do people get their tickets and what's
the cost involved tickets are at mount
austin lodge.com it's 95
for the sunday ticket or for the
saturday ticket and 195 for the chef's
table on sunday i've seen everyone on
social media going it looks like the
most amazing time i want to go one more
time chef will you tell me the name of
that i gotta hear you so this is a uh
eggplant
with uh
ricotta salata and fresh basil and
mainly oh i love how you say it just
rolled off the tongue thank you guys so
much jillian i'll send it over to you
i'm just gonna